نحن في اعلى هذا البرج السكني هذه المنطقه
التي
اشتعل فعل الغاره على هذا
البرج اجزاء
كبيره هذا البرج الشهداء كما نتابع ونشاهد
هنا شهداء وهنا اشلاء هذا البرج الذي
دمرته المقاتلات
الحربيه يعني حسب ما يتحدث لنا الان طواقم
الانقاذ والاطفاء في جهاز الدفاع المدني
بوجود
تحت تحت
رجلها طلعنا من هنا هي الخامسه ولا
السادسه
السادس لازالت فرق الانقاذ وطواقم الدفاع
المدني هنا في برج مشه تحاول انتشال
الشهداء
الذين يتم انتشال كام هذا المنزل احمد دير
بالك تقع احمد بتفر بتقع غ نتابع واياكم
هذا الشهيد ويعني هنا طارق مشتهى هذا على
ما يبدو يعني هويه الشهيد طارق مشتهى كانت
بجيبه واحد افراد الدفاع المدني الان
يعرفهم على هويه هذا الشهيد وهو طارق
مشتهى حيث التقى شهيدا نياره الاحتلال على
رج السكني في
منطقه سبت مقص مهد
رغم قله الامكانيات تعمل هذه الطواقم
لانتشال
اش
شغوف سكر
سكر طلعنا من ه السبعه الله يعطيك العافيه
قديش عد شدا طلعتو من هذا المنزل تقريبا
سبعه من هنا من ضمنهم طفله وراجل
وب تقريبا عمر 20 25 سنه وثنتين نساء
الثلاثينات اربعينات زي هيك يعني نحن
نشاهد ان الادا الطوابق العليه لهذا البرج
واجهت صعوبه في هذا الاستهداف يعني اكيد
احنا نناشد كمان يعني جميع عامه المواطنين
انهم يحاولوا قدر المستطاع انهم ما
يتواجدوا في الاماكن العلويه لانه بم
استهدافها
يعني غالبا بتم استهدافه في المدفعيه ولكن
هذا صرو 16 حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل ناس
مدنيين
يعني واحجي
معي يلا يا عم يا عم سلام
[موسيقى]
ياعم
a